Okay, let's try to apply the CSS rules to
our DOM tree. The first div rule would set the
text color to red, which is a property that
cascades down to the Hello text. This next rule makes
the paragraph contents to be displayed in black and
here's the font part. The rule applies to all paragraph
nodes regardless of its parent. Hence we change the
color of the text to black for Hello and world.
Finally, we get to our last rule, which tells us that any paragraph node
that has a div as its parent should be hidden from the render tree. As
a result, we can prune this branch from our render tree and all we're left with
is world. So, the final answer is world and the text color is black.